Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
đấu Bảo Nam Vlog video ngày hôm nay đâu
bạn ah blog xe chia sẻ với bạn cách chèn
ảnh trong Word và các thao tác căn chỉnh
hình ảnh và văn bản
Hà Nội dung chính của video này đâu bà
Nam cốc sẽ chia thành hai phần phần thứ
nhất đó là thao tác chèn ảnh vào Word
và phần thứ hai đó chính là các thao tác
căn chỉnh hình ảnh và văn bản
nội dung thứ nhất đó là cách chèn ảnh
vào word gia sư ở phía dưới này đâu bà
Nam vào lớp đã chuẩn bị sẵn một nội dung
văn bản và bây giờ mình sẽ chèn hình ảnh
vào giữa cái đoạn thứ nhất và đoạn thứ
hai này thấy các bước bạn thực hiện như
sau
bước thứ nhất bạn đặt dấu nháy chuột vào
vị trí Cần chèn Ví dụ ở đây là vị trí
này
sau đó vứt ngay bạn thấy và yên xuất
simmons
chọn picture
A và chọn cái gì vai
một số phiên bản ghót cũ hơn thì bạn chỉ
cần Click vào picture Tuy nhiên ở đây
mình đang dùng word 2021 do vậy mình sẽ
cần phải click thêm vào dòng giết đi vay
để chèn ảnh từ máy tính
và sau đó bạn tìm đến một hình ảnh cần
chèn ở trong máy tính Ví dụ mình sẽ đánh
này
bạn cứ choảng và Krystal in search
như vậy mình đã chèn ảnh vào văn bản
xong
Tiếp theo mình sẽ sang phần like đó là
căn chỉnh hình ảnh và văn bản
sau khi bạn chèn ảnh vào văn bản luật
thi để điều chỉnh kích thước của anh bạn
chỉ cần Click vào ảnh để chọn ạ
sau đó bạn đưa chuột vào một trong bốn
góc của ảnh ví dụ góc chia này
khi con trỏ chuột chuyển sang hình mũi
tên hai đầu thì bạn chỉ cần click và giữ
chuột trái sau đó kéo chuột để điều
chỉnh kích thước
như vậy mình đã điều chỉnh kích thước
của ảnh xong ở trong trường hợp bạn muốn
tạo cái ta cho ảnh thì bạn vẫn cứ chụp
ảnh
sau đó bạn thích vào Tab format
ta đây Bạn phải chọn một số mẫu sai có
sẵn
khi bạn Di chuột qua mẫu tay nào thấy
hình ảnh sẽ được thay đổi theo kiểu sau
đó
Ngoài ra bạn có thể kích vào cái phần
picture effect
và bạn phải chọn một số kiểu ví dụ các
kiểu lý khách này
vân vân và đây giảm giờ mình sẽ chọn cho
một kiểu Style đơn giản
kiểu bóng rổ
a
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang một nội dung nữa
đó là viết chữ đề này hoặc ảnh đề nên
chữ vân vân
sau khi bạn thích chụp ảnh thì bạn sẽ
nhìn thấy có một cái cân questek ở đây
hoặc Bạn có thể thích vào cái nút alt
ích xong cái Thanh ribbon
Nếu bạn muốn viết chữ đen thế này thì
bạn có thể chọn bị hightech có nghĩa là
ảnh ở đằng sau chữ
Và nếu bạn muốn ảnh đèn anh chứ thì bạn
có thể chọn infratech
Ngoài ra bạn có thể chọn một số kiểu
gôtích khác ví dụ như Square 2 rút vân
vân để điều chỉnh cái vị trí của ảnh
video này mình phải chọn cái kịp đây
và bây giờ mình sẽ kéo hình Ừ thế bạn
thấy văn bản sẽ bao quanh cái hình ảnh
này theo cái vị trí mà mình đã chọn Ví
dụ mình chẳng vị trí này
và như vậy trong nội dung với đâu mà rồi
đâu Bảo Nam vừa chia sẻ với bạn cách
chèn ảnh vào Word và một số thao tác căn
chỉnh hình ảnh và văn bản
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Nếu bạn có
những câu hỏi cần được hỗ trợ bạn hãy
comment chia bảo thế giới này Xin chào
và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở các video tiếp theo
Ừ
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào nay và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ đó bà Nam bớp đồng
thời Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video hữu ích từ đỗ bà Nam gấu Xin
cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa đỗ vào Nam vào lúc
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam vip.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nếu bà Năm blog để xem
thêm các video cũng như thủ thuật máy
tính tay Proshow Producer
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ Bà Năm có lúc chúng
con để cập nhật những bài viết đối mới
nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào em
năm nay bạn ở các video tiếp theo